when Sandra found out she was pregnant
for the first time it was a surprise but
a welcome one
like many soon-to-be mothers she was
nervous but assumed that during labor
she would be made to feel safe
she was wrong I was very shocked to find
out when accessing maternity care I was
sent home five times I was dismissed I
was ignored it felt as if I didn't care
my basic human rights I don't believe
were met in fact I felt like I was a
pain or a nuisance I was told that my
cries on my screen didn't coincide with
my labor contractions so I felt quite
dehumanizing at the time and I I was so
upset you know Sandra was so traumatized
by her experiences she quit her day job
to start campaigning full time on the
issue where she quickly learned that
many other women that looked like her
had similar stories to share
data shows that black women are four
times more likely to die than white
women due to complications Asian women
were almost twice as likely to die than
white women and women living in the most
deprived areas were two and a half times
more likely to die than those living in
the least
and whilst the data is shocking it's not
new
the government acknowledged these
disparities last year and committed to
setting up a task force to explore the
reasons for these poor outcomes but a
damning new report by MP says that
whilst the task force is necessary it's
currently insufficient the task force
doesn't have specific metrics that it's
measuring its outcomes so the reality is
that if you're not measuring what the
interventions are achieving if you're
not getting data in real time so that
you can see those interventions whether
they're working or not and therefore
roll out the ones that are successful
then really it isn't much more than a
talking shop
the government says it's invested 165
million pounds since 2021 to grow the
maternity Workforce and has a plan in
place to tackle disparities on a local
level to improve outcomes for all
mothers
but Sandra says that women of color
cannot be protected when the racism that
they experience is ignored it exists and
is alive unfortunately and is affecting
and killing black women on a day-to-day
basis and our children as well
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News